[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Dunja Hayali
schönen guten Abend von wem stammen die
Drohnen mit denen Moskau heute früh
angegriffen wurde die Aussagen dazu sind
wie zu erwarten unterschiedlich der
Kreml beschuldigt die Ukraine und nennt
es Terror die Ukraine wiederum
bestreitet etwas damit zu tun gehabt zu
haben allerdings sollte man ganz genau
hinhören denn der ukrainische
präsidentenberater podoljak sagte man
habe nichts direkt damit zu tun dieses
direkt lästern doch Fragen offen fest
steht beide hauptstädte sind heute mit
Drohnen angegriffen worden Christiane
Hoffmann
im russischen Staatsfernsehen sind die
Drohnen Angriffe auf Moskau das große
Thema des Abends ganz klar ist auch wer
der Feind ist für sie sind es
ukrainische Terroristen das sogenannte
Nazi-Regime in Kiew unterstützt uns
geleitet von NATO und den USA
die Einschläge am Morgen haben die
Russen sichtlich überrascht laut
russischem Verteidigungsministerium
seien acht Drohnen über Moskau geflogen
die meisten seien zerstört worden drei
hätten Wohnhäuser leicht beschädigt zwei
Anwohner sein verletzt worden
gegen vier Uhr morgens gab es einen
lauten Knall und einen großen Lichtblitz
der irgendwo sehr nah eingeschlagen ist
natürlich beunruhigt uns das es ist an
der Zeit mit dieser Ukraine Schluss zu
machen sie fertig zu machen
Präsident Putin wirft der Ukraine
Terrorismus gegen zivile Gebäude vor und
droht sie provozieren uns es ihnen
gleich zu tun und sie müssen verstehen
dass es eine andere Gefahr gibt dass die
Arbeit an der Atomanlage saporisha
unterbrochen werden könnte
die Ukraine bestreitet eine direkte
Beteiligung in eine Radiosendung sagte
der Berater von Präsident selenski wir
beobachten das mit Vergnügen und haben
damit natürlich keine direkte Verbindung
vor allem im wohlhabenden Westen der
russischen Hauptstadt wurden die Drohnen
gesichtet und abgeschossen es seien
aufklärungsdrohnen gewesen die einem
psychologische Wirkung erzeugen und das
Bewusstsein für den Krieg wohl nach
Moskau tragen sollten so Experten
waren schon mit ziemlicher Sicherheit
die ukrainischen Streitkräfte eine der
Drohnen wurde ja relativ gut
identifiziert also eine ukrainisches
Produkt bei einer anderen Drohne handelt
es sich vermutlich um einen um eine
Drohne die seit 2021 in Entwicklung ist
und wahrscheinlich auch ukrainische
Herkunft
Kriegslärm und schlaflose Nächte
wochenlang die Moskauer müssen das nicht
ertragen Kiew und andere ukrainische
Städte erleben dagegen seit Wochen die
schlimmsten russischen Angriffe
vergangene Nacht wurde ein Tier war
getötet Bürgermeister Klitschko nennt es
genutzt
die Ukraine ohne Ukraine das ist
Terrorismus
über das Leid der Ukraine berichtet das
russische Staatsfernsehen nicht den
Angriffskrieg auf ihren Nachbarland
verkaufen sie weiterhin als notwendige
Selbstverteidigung
bei seinem Besuch kürzlich in Berlin
versicherte der ukrainische Präsident
das ein Land das russische Territorium
nicht angreifen wird also wer steckt
hinter den Drohnenangriffen auf Moskau
fragen wir nach in Russland und in der
Ukraine beginnen wir mit dem Krüger in
Kiew was ist denn von diesem wir haben
nichts direkt damit zu tun zu halten
also das lässt zumindest Raum für
Spekulation dass die Ukraine eben
indirekt doch etwas damit zu tun hat und
der ukrainische Präsidenten Berater
podoljak hat heute allerdings hier im
Fernsehen noch mehr gesagt dass die
Ukraine ganz definitiv nichts damit zu
tun hat also das ist eine relativ klare
Aussage die allerdings immer kommt in
solchen Fällen von Seiten der Ukraine
das ist ein gängiges Muster so war es
auch beim Drohnenangriff Anfang dieses
Monats auf den Kreml auch damals hat die
Ukraine gesagt wir haben nichts damit zu
tun aber dann gab es eben doch Hinweise
das womöglich ukrainische Kreise daran
beteiligt gewesen sein könnten dann gibt
es natürlich auch noch die zeitliche
Komponente also dieser Angriffe auf
Moskau kommen genau zu einem Zeitpunkt
da die Ukraine massiv unter Beschuss
steht also das ganze sieht schon nach
Gegenschlag aus und moskau sieht durch
diese Angriffe natürlich nicht gut aus
und das kommt der Ukraine ganz
sicherlich nicht umlegen dann fragen wir
doch auch nach in Moskau bei Vögel gab
für den Kreml ist der Angreifer klar
Putin hat sich zu den Drohnen Angriffen
sogar selbst geäußert macht er ja
insgesamt eher selten wie deutest du das
alles
ja das stimmt normalerweise lässt sich
der russische Präsident vor allem auch
mehr Zeit bevor er aktuelle
Entwicklungen kommentiert auffällig war
heute auch sein Tonfall dieser Kommentar
der viel quasi beiläufig am Rande einer
Veranstaltung die zu einem ganz anderen
Thema stattfand und Präsident Putin hat
die Vorfälle eben nicht genutzt um die
Eskalationsspirale weiter zu drehen er
hat zwar angedeutet dass er befürchte
dass es von ukrainischer Seite Versuche
geben könne Sabotage Akte durchzuführen
am Atomkraftwerk sapor değil aber
insgesamt war das was er da gesagt hat
verglichen mit dem was wir sonst schon
von ihm gehört haben eher zurückhaltend
womöglich sucht man im Kreml noch nach
der passenden Antwort auf die Attacken
von heute Morgen und ganz sicher möchte
man den Eindruck vermitteln dass man die
Lage im Griff habe aber natürlich werfen
diese Vorfälle viele Fragen auf und die
drängen sie davon die richtet sich wohl
anders Verteidigungsministerium das
behauptet ja es habe heute morgen 8
Drohnen abgefangen andere kremlar
Quellen sprechen von weitaus mehr
unbemannten Flugobjekten von bis zu 30
und die Frage die sich aufdrängt ist
natürlich wie konnten es die so eine
Anzahl von Drohnen unbemerkt und
ungestört bis zur russischen Hauptstadt
schaffen also viele Fragen noch in
Moskau offen noch mal eine an Dich Tim
in Kiew die Angriffe haben in diesem
Monat ja massiv zugenommen auch in der
Hauptstadt sogar tagsüber was macht das
eigentlich mit den Menschen in der
Hauptstadt
also zunächst einmal wirkt das Leben
hier tagsüber eigentlich äußerlich
relativ normal es sind viele Menschen
auf der Straße ist es sommerlich aber
wenn man mit den Menschen spricht dann
sagen sie am natürlich schon dass sie
angespannt sind dass sie müde sind
allein seit dem Wochenende sind hier
Dutzende von Raketen und Drohnen allein
auf keep abgeschossen worden und das
macht natürlich etwas mit dem Menschen
dass macht vermürbt sie und ich denke
dass das auch eine Taktik ist dass
versucht wird die Ukraine und
Ukrainerinnen langsam aber sicher müde
zu machen in diesem Krieg diese Taktik
gab es seitens Russland schon einmal und
zwar im Winter als vor allem die
ukrainische Infrastruktur massiv
beschossen worden ist damit sollte das
Leben der Menschen hier schwieriger
werden aber das hat auch damals schon
nicht funktioniert auch damals haben die
Menschen durchgehalten dann vielen Dank
für eure Einschätzungen nach Kiew und
nach Moskau
ja und jetzt droht mitten in Europa noch
ein anderer Alter Konflikt zu eskalieren
und zwar in der Republik Kosovo das Land
das zu 90% ethnisch albanisch ist hat
sich 2008 ja von Serbien abgespalten die
Unabhängigkeitserklärung sorgt seitdem
aber immer wieder im überwiegend
serbischen Norden der Republik für
Spannungen und scharmütze und auch im
angrenzenden Serbien selbst diese
Spannungen die Arten nun in Gewalt aus
inklusive verletzter natursoldaten
anders dafür waren Kommunalwahlen bei
denen Kosovo Albaner erfolgreich
abgeschnitten hatten weil die meisten
der dort lebenden Serben die Weinen
boykottierten das nun sehr gut resident
da startet die Max ein bisschen zu früh
das nun der Präsident Vucic seine Armee
die höchste Alarmbereitschaft versetzt
hat ist da wenig hilfreich um die
Situation zu deeskalieren sollte er das
überhaupt wollen denn außenpolitisch
spielt wucic ein doppeltes Spiel er
pflegt enge Beziehungen zu Russland
während er gleichzeitig eine
EU-Mitgliedschaft anstrebt seit elf
Jahren sind sie aus serbischer Sicht
Beitrittskandidat in frustrierter
Wartestellung die Kosovo Frage könnte
der Joker des Präsidenten sein Britta
Hilpert
über 30 Verletzte KV Soldaten am Boden
was gestern geschah hat eine neue
Qualität sie sollen hier im Kosovo
eigentlich den Frieden sichern Frieden
zwischen ethnischen Serben und
ethnischen Albanern doch der ist nun
brüchig und die führenden Politiker bei
der Ethnien führen auch einen Krieg der
Worte Gruppe es waren extrem rechte die
alles attackierten und niederbrannten
was nicht serbisch war und die
nationalistische und showinistische
Symbole trugen so der Kurse wahre
Ministerpräsident Kurti der serbische
Präsident dagegen meint das sind ernste
und schwerere Ereignisse für die allein
Verantwortung trägt
es begann mit Kommunalwahlen in
nordkorsovo im April die Serben
boykottierten die nur albanerwelten die
Wahlbeteiligung lag bei rund
3,5%. und so gewannen allein albanische
Bürgermeister
Kosovo albanische Sicherheitskräfte
sollten Ihnen nun den Zugang zu den
Rathäusern sichern absehbar war dass die
örtliche serbische Mehrheit das
verhindern will das war der Auslöser der
Eskalation doch im kleinen Kosovo sind
Konflikte nie nur lokal alle fürchten
eine Neuauflage der Balkankriege
es gibt genug Gewalt in Europa sagte
EU-Außenbeauftragte und ruft zur
Zurückhaltung auf und der russische
Außenminister waren vor einer Explosion
die sich zusammenbraue er sieht USA und
NATO in der Verantwortung
und doch sprechen die Botschafter von
Ost und West getrennt voneinander wohl
bemerkt bei denn sein Wort hat Gewicht
im Kosovo und diese Botschafter wollen
wohl auch vermeiden dass er zu
hartleibig wird denn zu Hause steht der
massiv unter Druck wegen dieser Proteste
nach zwei tödlichen Amok laufen wächst
den Serbien die Wut über die Regierung
ihre Medien und die nationalistische
Hetze die sie verbreiten es sind die
größten
oppositionsprozesse seit Jahren davon
abzulenken ist jetzt momentan in seinem
Sinne die Probleme sie haben es wird es
auf Dauer natürlich ebenfalls nicht
lösen dieses zwischen den Stühlen sitzen
zwischen Westen und Osten wird auch für
zunehmen D schwieriger der
Scherbenhaufen im nordkorso wo ist auch
diplomatischer Natur der Junge EU
Friedensprozess zwischen Serben und
Kosovo Albanern ist zerschlagen er muss
von vorne beginnen wenn es nur friedlich
bleibt dafür schickt die NATO 700
weitere K vor Soldaten und die USA
verlangen vom Kosovo seine
Sicherheitskräfte abzuziehen morgen aber
wollen diese haben sich hier wieder
versammeln
und wir kommen noch mal zurück zum
russischen Angriffskrieg je länger der
dauert desto größer werden natürlich
auch die Erwartungen der baltischen
Nachbarn Gundula und zwar an die NATO
Bundespräsident Steinmeier hat in
Litauen dem eu- und NATO-Mitglied die
weitere Unterstützung Deutschlands
zugesichert gemeinsam würde jeder
Quadratzentimeter des bündnisgebietes
verteidigt darauf können sich auch
Litauen verlassen
angesichts des russischen Krieges
forderte Litauens Präsidenten aus Seda
erneut eine stärkere nato-präsenz in den
baltischen Staaten die Bundeswehr führt
bereits eine nato-kampfverband in
Litauen an Steinmeier wurde von
Angehörigen einige der 760 deutschen
Soldaten begleitet
ein klares Zeichen gegen russischen
Imperialismus wird von dem EU-Gipfel am
Donnerstag in Moldau erwartet um die
Wirtschaft des EU-Beitrittskandidaten zu
stabilisieren hat die EU die
Finanzhilfen für das kleine Nachbarland
der Ukraine verdoppelt die Hilfskredite
werden auf 295 Millionen Euro
aufgestockt
der deutsch-französische
batteriezellenhersteller Acc hat in
Nordfrankreich ein erstes großes Werk
eröffnet zur Produktion von Batterien
für Elektrofahrzeuge die Fabrik sei ein
wichtiger Beitrag zur Unabhängigkeit der
europäischen Automobilindustrie von
Asien sagte Bundesverkehrsminister
Wissing zur Eröffnung des Werks bei
dufra Deutschland und Frankreich fördern
das Gemeinschaftsunternehmen von
Mercedes stelantis und des
Energiekonzerns Total mit 1,3 Milliarden
Euro
zu den wirtschaftlichen Abhängigkeiten
Deutschlands von China später im heute
journal Update ein Gespräch mit Clemens
Fust vom ifo-Institut
bundesinnenministerin Fräser will
vorerst keine stationären
Grenzkontrollen an der
deutsch-polnischen Grenze einrichten man
setzte zunächst auf eine erhöhte
Polizeipräsenz um illegale Migration zu
senken dafür sollen mehrere
Hundertschaften der Bundespolizei
zusätzlich eingesetzt werden so die
Ministerin beim Besuch eines Deutsch
polnischen Zentrums für Polizei und Zoll
Zusammenarbeit Polen zählte bis Mai
bereits über 10.000
illegale Grenzübertritte aus Belarus
77 Fragen rund ums heizungsgesetz darum
ging es heute und geht es immer noch bei
einem Treffen in Berlin gestellt hat die
Fragen die FDP Robert Habeck sollte sie
beantworten im Beisein von Abgeordneten
der Ampel nachdem es ja wochenlang
Streit Schuldzuweisungen und Spitzen gab
sollten heute die Blockaden abgebaut und
die Temperatur bei allen Beteiligten
runtergekühlt werden durch klären
erklären miteinander reden und eventuell
auch durch weitere Kompromisse einige
hatte Robert Habeck ja bereits angeboten
so könnte das Startdatum für Altbauten
nach hinten verschoben werden zudem soll
es mehr technologieoffenheit geben
Stichwort Holzpellets zudem will der
Minister die Planung für Kommunen mit
denen für private Hausbesitzer abstimmen
und die Härtefallregelung soll
nachgebessert werden
blicken wir auf das Treffen heute in
Berlin wie alle betonen das ist keine
Verhandlungsrunde hat das für uns
natürlich trotzdem
im Blick einen schönen guten Abend nach
Berlin Theo Ergebnisse gibt es also
keine und wird es auch keine geben wird
denn zumindest eine Ausfahrt aus dem
festgefahrenen Streit möglicherweise
gefunden
ich glaube das ist nicht das Thema des
heutigen Abends das Gespräch hat ja um
20 Uhr begonnen und es ist zeitlich nach
hinten nicht begrenzt angesichts der
gerade erwähnten 77 fdp-fragen an dem
Minister und sicher auch diverser
Nachfragen klingt endeoffen ja auch
durchaus sinnvoll wir sagen das Gespräch
läuft die Zwischentöne rund um den
heizungsstreit sind aktuell innerhalb
der Ampel weniger hitzig und von den
meisten Beteiligten wird auch sprachlich
eher abgerüstet viele ampelvertreter
wollen glaube ich mittlerweile in
ruhigeres Fahrwasser kommen nicht nur
weil nach dem wochenlangen Krach ja die
Umfragen jetzt ergeben dass die Ampel
keine eigene Mehrheit mehr hätte und
dass viele Bürger mit der Arbeit der
Koalition unzufrieden sind man darf
nicht vergessen die Ampel läuft ja auch
sehenden Auges in die nächste Krise und
zwar den Streit um den deutlich dünner
gewordenen Sparhaushalt er ist den
meisten koalitionieren hier klar dass
sie das heizungsthema bald abräumen
sollten um nicht im vielfach Streit in
die Sommerpause zu gehen deshalb
wird man heute so lange reden wie nötig
harvek und sein neuer Staatssekretär
treffen dann diese Woche noch die
beteiligten Verbände und das wiederum
fließt dann einen in die weiteren
politischen Gespräche zeitgleich
verhandeln die viel zu Chefs der
Fraktion alles also Abstimmungsprozesse
die man sich eigentlich vor der ganzen
öffentlichen Aufregung gewünscht hätte
aus dem Bauministerium hieß es übrigens
am Abend die Ampel habe sich jetzt
grundsätzlich auf ein Gesetz für
kommunale wärmeplanung geeinigt damit
sollen Kommunen in die Pflicht genommen
werden wärmepläne vorzulegen damit klar
wird welche Häuser ans fern oder nah
Wärmenetz angeschlossen werden können
auch das wäre klugerweise schon Teil
eines ersten Entwurfs gewesen vielleicht
lernt ja der ein oder die andere was
dann aus dieser Quintessenz diese Woche
auf soll auf jeden Fall weiter geredet
werden sind wir gespannt wann sich das
Parlament dann mit dem Gebäude
Energiegesetz wirklich beschäftigen kann
oder wer Theo vielen Dank
er gilt als der Architekt der cum-ex
Deals heute wurde Steueranwalt hanno
Berger wegen schwerer
Steuerhinterziehung zu acht Jahren und
drei Monaten Haft verurteilt was er
gemacht hat stellen Sie sich das in etwa
so vor sie bekommen im Supermarkt einen
Pfandbon aus dem Automaten den kopieren
Sie so oft Sie wollen und gehen dann mit
all diesen Kopien an die Kasse um sich
all das Pfannen dass sie nie gezahlt
haben auszahlen zu lassen genau das
wurde im cumex Skandal gemacht mit dem
Unterschied dass es um Milliarden und
falschen Steuerbescheinigung bzw Steuern
ging und diese wurden halt immer und
immer und immer wieder erstattet obwohl
sie nie gezahlt wurden Christoph
Schneider über den Fall eines Mannes der
heute zum zweiten Mal verurteilt wurde
mit Unverständnis verfolgte Angeklagte
72-Jährige Steueranwalt hanno Berger die
gut 90-minütige mündliche
Urteilsbegründung der Vorsitzenden
Richterin detailliert liegt die
Wirtschaftsstrafkammer des Landgerichts
Wiesbaden da warum sie drei Fälle der
schweren Steuer Hinterziehung als
erwiesen ansieht dabei ist das Gericht
davon ausgegangen dass der Angeklagte
Herr Dr Berger als Initiator und
steuerlicher und rechtlicher Berater
einer GmbH den Steueranspruch des
Staates verkürzt hat und dabei den
Schaden auch billigend in Kauf genommen
hat 113 Millionen Euro Gesamtschaden bis
zuletzt sah sich hanno Berger als Opfer
eines justizskandals wie es stets
sämtliche Vorwürfe der
Generalstaatsanwaltschaft Frankfurt am
Main vehement zurück
doch auch seine beiden Verteidiger
konnten sich mit ihrem durchaus
eigenwilligen Mandanten nicht auf eine
klare Verteidigungsstrategie
verständigen es ist in der
unterhaltsbegründung der Vorsitzenden
auch durchaus klar gesagt worden dass es
nicht sein kann dass man bestimmte
steuerliche Aspekte
herauspickt und dann zu einem für sich
vernünftigen Gesamtbild zusammensteckt
weil so funktioniert das deutsche
Strafrecht nicht so stellte der
Bundesgerichtshof die oberste Instanz in
Strafsachen vor zwei Jahren in einem
Grundsatz Urteil fest dass
cum-ex-geschäfte klar als Straftat
einzustufen sind es handelt sich bei den
praktizierten Geschäften weder um legale
Gestaltungsmodelle noch um das bloße
ausnutzen eine Gesetzeslücke
weil die gesetzliche Regelung eindeutig
war eine Lücke gab es hier nicht
Wirtschaftswissenschaftler wie Christoph
spengel sehen in den cum-ex-geschäften
den größten steuerraub in der Geschichte
der Bundesrepublik mit einer zentralen
Figur hanno Berger hanno Berger hat die
cumex-geschäfte in die bankreise
hereingetragen er hat sie erklärt er hat
sich strukturiert und hat damit erstens
ein lukratives Geschäftsmodell für
Banken geschaffen und es war seine
zweite Rolle dass er sozusagen Steuer
aggressive Investoren dazu bewegen
konnte in cum-ex-geschäfte zu
investieren das Landgericht ordnete
neben der Haftstrafe von 8 Jahren und 3
Monaten außer dem die Einziehung von
rund einer Millionen Euro von Hannovers
Vermögen an gegen seine Verurteilung
wird der Revision beim Bundesgerichtshof
in Karlsruhe einlegen
und wir bleiben in der Welt der Finanzen
Gundula und schauen da jetzt auf die
Folgen der Zinswende
im zugesteigende Zinsen suchen und
finden immer mehr Bankkunden gute
Konditionen für Tages- und Festgeld so
sind die Einlagen deutscher Geldhäuser
auf eine Rekordhöhe gestiegen wir fragen
Frank Bethmann an der Börse nicht alle
Banken und Sparkassen geben die Zinsen
weiter warum nicht naja sind im
Augenblick vor allem viele Sparkassen
und Volksbanken die nicht oder wenig
insbesondere aus Tagesgeld geben sie
betreuen die Einlagen von besonders
vielen Kunden die Sparkasse gilt als
Marktführer im Privatkundengeschäft und
viele Sparkassen und Volksbanken setzen
schlicht und ergreifend auf die Treue
ihrer Kunden dass diejenigen etwas mehr
Zinsen woanders nicht einfach die Bank
wechseln das rentiert sich durchaus man
kann sich ausrechnen was bei den
Finanzhäusern hängen bleibt wenn sie das
Geld ihrer Kunden für den aktuellen
Anlage Zins von 3,25% bei der EZB parken
und selbst kaum Zinsen dafür
weiterreichen und wenn es denn Zinsen
gibt bewegen sie sich in welchem Rahmen
ja das ist das schöne am Wettbewerb es
gibt selbstverständlich Banken die
durchaus Zinsen zahlen nicht nur aufs
Tagesgeld das Festgeld feiert ein wahres
Comeback festgeldeinlagen deutscher
Banken sind auf ein Rekordniveau
gestiegen nämlich auf
535 Milliarden Euro eben auch weil die
Konditionen wieder halbwegs attraktiv
sind laut im Vergleichsportal Verivox
beträgt der Durchschnittszins bei
zweijährigen Festgeld derzeit 2,06% pro
Jahr verglichen mit einer Inflation von
zuletzt über 7%, ist es natürlich immer
noch eher wenig doch viele Anleger sagen
sich offenbar besser wenig als gar
nichts wie die Jahre zuvor
vielen Dank
im Wettstreit mit den USA um die
Vorreiterrolle auch im All hat China
erstmals einen Zivilisten zu seiner Raum
geschickt ein Wissenschaftler von der
Pekinger Universität für Luft und
Raumfahrt startete mit zwei teilkonauten
ins All sechseinhalb Stunden später
durfte die Rakete an der Raumstation an
die Crew will die kommenden sechs Monate
für wissenschaftliche Experimente nutzen
eine Meldung vom Sport Tennisstar
Alexander Zverev ist erfolgreich in die
French Open gestartet mit einem Sieg
gegen den Südafrikaner Lloyd Harris ein
Befreiungsschlag für den 26-Jährigen
nach seiner schweren Knöchelverletzung
auf dem Platz in Roland Garros vor einem
Jahr
der österreichische Schauspieler peter
Simonischek ist im Alter von 76 Jahren
in Wien gestorben
international bekannt wurde er durch die
Titelrolle in der Vater Tochter
Geschichte Toni Erdmann auch dafür wurde
der leidenschaftliche Schauspieler
ausgezeichnet
jahrzehntelang wirkte er am Wiener
Burgtheater bei den Salzburger
Festspielen und auch auf deutschen
Bühnen aktuell ist Simonischek im Kino
zu sehen in der zdf-co-produktion der
vermessene Mensch über einen Berliner
Ethnologen
wer schon mal im Pergamonmuseum war weiß
was das für ein faszinierender Ort ist
mit dem monumentalen Pergamon-Altar
weswegen ist das Museum ja überhaupt nur
gibt oder dem ichtator das Teil der
Stadtmauer Babylons war oder oder oder
wer in den Genuss dieser Anblicke noch
kommen möchte der muss sich allerdings
beeilen von Ende Oktober an wird das
Museum für mindestens dreieinhalb Jahre
komplett geschlossen der Südflügel sogar
für ganze 14 Jahre eine komplett
Schließung wollte man vermeiden aber sie
ist nicht zu vermeiden warum und auch
warum die Kosten für die Renovierung so
explodiert sind Stefan Merseburger
glücklich kann sich schätzen wer diese
Preziosen noch zu Gesicht bekommt die
babylonische Prozessionsstraße und das
isstatur bis Oktober sind sie noch zu
sehen dann verschwinden diese Publikums
Lieblinge des Pergamonmuseums für ewige
14 Jahre ein sturzgefährdete Licht
Decken sind nur ein Grund das ganze
Museum ist dringend
renovierungsbedürftig
es ist ja unsere Kernaufgabe wir sollen
die Dinge bewahren dafür ist diese ganze
Baumaßnahme nötig und dafür ist es eben
auch nötig dieses schöne Tor
zunächst mal zu verstecken um es dann
später wieder in einer besseren in einem
besseren Zustand in einem Haus das in
einem besseren Zustand ist wieder zu
zeigen
seit 2013 wird das Pergamonmuseum
renoviert fertig sein soll es 2037 und
dann samt Erweiterungsbau so aussehen
der Zeitaufwand ist so gigantisch wie
die Kosten anfänglich ging man von 240
Millionen Euro aus mittlerweile landet
man bei bis zu 1,5 Milliarden da gibt es
natürlich enorme Preissteigerungen die
man mit natürlich mit einem Preisen muss
im pergamemuseum etwa sind an allen
Ecken und Enden Schäden aus dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg noch er hat die Gebäude nach
dem Krieg entstand gesetzt aber nicht
grundsaniert seit über 100 Jahren die
Museumsinsel wurde auf einer Sumpf
Mannschaft errichtet der Baugrund ist
äußerst kompliziert manche der Häuser
stehen auf Eichenpfählen der Südflügel
des Pergamonmuseums mit markttor von
Milet und isstatur wurde auf einer
Stahlbetonbrücke über die schwimmerde
gebaut diese Brücke hat Risse die
Rahmenbedingungen sind einfach so wie
sie sind und damit muss man arbeiten und
das wirkt sich natürlich auf das aus wie
wir planen müssen wir stoßen hier im
Pergamonmuseum trotz allem immer wieder
auf Überraschungen böse Überraschungen
eigentlich sollte das Museum bei
laufendem Betrieb saniert werden ab
Oktober nun wird der Garant für gute
Besucherzahlen komplett geschlossen für
mindestens dreieinhalb Jahre danach kann
man den Namen gebenden Pergamonaltar
endlich wieder betrachten
[Musik]
das Schwerste was sie auf der
Museumsinsel errichtet wurde aber es ist
natürlich ein einzigartiger Ort der
Weltkultur UNESCO Welt Erde und
natürlich haben wir die Verpflichtung
die Dinge zu erhalten und in die Zukunft
zu führen
2027 werden Pergamon Alter und dennoch
Flügel des Museums grundsaniert eröffnen
wenn alles gut geht sicher dagegen ist
so ein Glanzstück geht mächtig ins Geld
wir empfehlen also gehen sie hin bis
Ende Oktober und jetzt empfehlen wir
Ihnen 37 Grad wie weiterleben wenn
Angehörige bei einem Unfall sterben
und um Mitternacht meldet sich Wulff
schmiese mit unserem heute journal
Updates das war es von uns beiden machen
sie es gut wo auch immer sie sind
tschüss tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend morgen geht mit dem Mai auch
der meteorologische Frühling zu Ende er
war etwas kühler etwas drüber und
deutlich nasser als im vierjährigen
klimatologischen Mittel der Jahren 1991
bis 2020 zu erwarten gewesen wäre im
gesamten Frühling sind deutschlandweit
so 200 Liter pro Quadratmeter gefallen
jetzt im Mai gab es aber große
Unterschiede hier Nordosten kamen kaum
fünf Liter zusammen aber in den
westlichen Mittelgebirgen unterm
Alpenrand waren es total über 200 Liter
pro Quadratmeter bei uns ist das Wetter
ja zur Zeit sehr ruhig das sieht in
Italien aber auch in Spanien und auch im
südlichen Osteuropa ganz anders aus da
gibt's kräftige Gewitter kräftige
Regenschauer und interessant ist aktuell
auch noch das ist in fast ganz Europa
Temperaturen zwischen 20 und 25 Grad
gibt von Zypern bis Irland aber auch von
Warschau bis zu den Kanarischen Inseln
bei uns sind die Temperaturen heute
Nacht auf 12 Grad im Rhein-Main-Gebiet
und bis drei Grad in Uckermark dort
reicht es also am Boden noch mal für
Frost meist ist der Himmel kristallklar
und morgen gibt es dann wieder viel
Sonnenschein und einige Wolkenfelder im
Norden aus den Alpen heraus reicht es
vielleicht nur für einen kleinen
Regenschauer bei Ostwind hier im
Alpenvorland an der Nordsee bleibt es
immer noch bei diesem nord-nordwestwind
und deswegen bleibt an der Küste auch
kühl mit nur 15 Grad sonst werden 20 bis
28 Grad erreicht und an diesem Wetter
ändert sich in den nächsten Tagen gar
nichts ich wünsche Ihnen einen schönen
Abend